puzzle objects been around a long time
it was first described in the paper in
around 1965 by a man could Lotfi a Zadeh
and it's been around it's been in
widespread usage for decades but there's
still a lot of advances being made in it
fuzzy logic is a way of dealing with
uncertainties which isn't something that
computers do naturally beside that
humans that were very well so normally
when we think of logic and when we think
of reasoning about things the way
computers tend to deal with things and
the way you might instantly think of
dealing with things is true/false 1 and
0 so for example you might classify
someone who's watching computer file as
deaf as watching it true or not watching
it false it's very simple there is only
one option or the other we have no in
between that's not the way that the real
world works
and that's not the way that humans work
so you can look out of your window now
and you can say today's nice weather
we're in England is likely not nice
weather but the definition of nice
varies from person to person with fuzzy
logic instead of just going with true
and false 1 & 0 we have a sliding scale
we have between that we have what's
called a degree of truth so I can look
out the window and say that today is
kind of iffy it's a bit sunny but some
clouds maybe it's 0.3 nice day or 0.7
nice day is this about the saying there
are no gray areas it's either black or
wise exactly yet there were always gray
areas and the gray areas vary from
person to person which we'll come back
to later
so logic is also very closely related to
sets and a set is a collection of things
so when we talk about st. being true or
false we also talk about there being a
set where something is true and if it's
not true they're not in that set so the
set of nice weather if I was going to
describe nice weather
I would probably decide that I don't be
like things too hot so nice is when it's
cold but cold enough to not wear a
jacket but to not too hot for me to feel
uncomfortable so that would be what we'd
call the membership function that gives
a value for certain things so if I check
the temperature and I see that it's
about 18 degrees there's no wind then
that probably fits into a 1 on my
niceness scale if it's no clouds at all
there's no shade anywhere it's 30
degrees that pretty is
closer to zero on my scale so you get
nice sliding graphs that gives us a way
of dealing with uncertainty so if we
look at this example on the board so
this is kind of the typical example for
fuzzy logic which you see everywhere
this could be a shower controller so
with temperature things don't just
suddenly go from hot to cold you have
different scales so what we have here is
free of these membership functions that
assign things to different values so for
example at a low temperature we know
that it's cold as it gets as the
temperature goes up it gets less cold
and then we start to see warm kicking it
so around the node we can decide this
put about 15 degrees I haven't put any
actual values on here so around this
area we now know that we're we're kind
of mixing warm and cold there's no it's
not strictly cold that's not strictly
warm and then we have the same story
with hot so this gives us a way of
dealing with the fact that the
temperature of water isn't strictly
boolean thing it's not strictly true or
false if we look at the shower
controller we know that at some point
someone has decided this is now no
longer cold and this is where warm
starts kicking in so although we're
dealing with uncertainties and we've got
this membership functions that allow us
to model them you still have someone
imposing their definition of that word
on to it someone still needs to decide
the values of the membership and that's
where things get very complicated and
when you're dealing with fuzzy expert
systems you often need to collect state
many sources and you have to use various
techniques to consolidate that data and
to train the system to be as accurate as
possible ok so when we talk about fuzzy
expert system we're basically talking
about a fuzzy system where the
membership functions and the values were
using have been fed in by experts in
some domain area so in our example here
would be experts in knowing what people
like in their showers they will decide
at a certain temperature this water is
no longer cold and it starts to get
towards warm unpleasant fuzzy logic
systems systems which use membership
functions like this and have these fuzzy
sets and have these degrees of truth are
very widely used in all sorts of things
you might not expect when you set the
setting on your washing machine it
doesn't just do it exactly the same way
every time it checks the load of the
wash it checks how dirty the water is
after each cycle through it does all
sorts of things to decide exactly what
temperature and exactly how fast to spin
to make sure that it's is eco efficient
and giving as good a wash as possible
one of the most famous examples of a
fuzzy logic system in use is the Sendai
railway Japan
this is a subway which is one of the
first uses of fuzzy logic that actually
measures have the weight on the train
how fast is going Spencer and all sorts
of these things to make sure that it
maintains a level and smooth travel this
diagram here is kind of showing a rough
outline of a fuzzy logic system we have
an input which X and Chris values so
these are things which aren't yet signed
a truth value they're not in a fuzzy set
but then we also fire them so we look at
on membership functions and we apply
some value to them then we have our
fuzzy sets and these go into our
inference system this is where all the
magic happens this is where we then
start from reasons so we have a rule
base and a rule a quit address on the
board so a rule has the form of an
anticipation is water is dirty then and
then this will also be a fuzzy set so
water is dirty this is a fuzzy set so
we're looking at our water which will
pointing to come from here and we'll
check it against the dirty membership
function so we go back to our shower
controller example and think about that
we might say if water is warm and we
check how much it's warm so save dirty
we had a membership function that some
sensor was checking the water to see how
dirty it was and if it was pitch-black
and the sensor detected it was very
dirty we could say that this is one and
so then we'd act on it in some way so we
then might say some other fuzzy set it's
a certain value so we would say then
spin very fast or add detergent or doing
have a rinse cycle any number of actions
and that gets on to the next point so we
actually have a rule basis multiple
rules for different membership functions
for different actions different outputs
and we run all of these rules through
them and then we combine them in this
inference engine that's what the
inference engine does it takes these
rules it flies the fuzzy sets to them
and it combines them to come up with
some output some decided action this
decide action is in the form of fuzzy
sets it then gets deposited as I
mentioned earlier they deal in
certainties they deal in Travolta's
adenine zeroes and ones
we need to default afire them to
something that the system can use and so
we diversify and we get critical add
users output so that's some action so go
back to the washing machine we take in
some measurements of the water
temperature and the water and how dirty
water is we apply those measurements to
our fuzzy sets so we know some
information about so we have some fuzzy
information some true values about how
hot and how dirty the water is we then
check those against overall basis and we
decide on some actions we decide how
fast it has been how much water should
be in the next rinse cycle how much
detergent we should mix it we remove the
fuzziness from that and we give a crisp
values output and then that actually is
undertaken by the system as well it's
not using for zero we'd probably end up
taking our measurements or Chris values
and instead applying an awful lot of if
statements to them so if I rub this out
and there then if temp is less than 30
and dirt is greater than six do rinse
cycle or something like this so you'd
have to do this over and over again once
we have all these rules built up the
build on this it looks very similar to
our rule base but the difference here is
that because we're describing these here
we haven't done anything with this
before we're describing its conditions
here we haven't done any of these values
before it's almost as if we're defining
our membership function in the
conditions and it's a much less concise
way of dealing with things it's not as
easily maintainable and changeable in
code it's just a bit messy to be honest
and if you wanted to if you decide that
some later date that your washing
machine would be more efficient if you'd
done a temperature value differently or
a dirt value differently and it'd be
much more hassle to go back for and
change or the system much more
maintainable words in this way we'd have
to change to rule itself we just change
our definition of dirty our use of is
somewhat hypocritical in that we don't
deal with all uncertainties our
measurements might be uncertain our
definitions might be uncertain so
there's continuing involvement sin
describing these uncertainties better
but the big problem is once you start
doing with more uncertainty it's the
computational demands start to really
build up and that's the current area
that is being tackled as well as there's
a numerous areas it's ahead very heavily
researched topic and it actually has
probably one of the largest abundance of
published papers for any individual
topic
you're trying to access this bit of
memory but that's not your memory that
doesn't belong to you or this program
there's a little programming Java
already anyone which is familiar with
basical understand all of that